répondre aux besoins des enfants grâce à
un accompagnement social et médical tous
les jours à l'externat médico éducatif
de la clé saint-pierre à elancourt des
jeunes polyhandicapés viennent ici pour
travailler sur des activités
quotidiennes
nous accompagnons 25 jeunes
polyhandicapés de ce héros à 20 ans ces
jeunes viennent tous les jours en
externat donc du matin jusqu'en fin
d'après midi
et c'est une équipe interdisciplinaire
dont qui propose un projet personnalisé
d'accompagnement à chacun une structure
que des étudiants de l'université de
versailles saint quentin ont décidé
d'aider dans le cadre de leur master ces
cinq jeunes ont créé un projet social en
faveur du centre
l'objectif récolter des fonds en vue de
la future journée portes ouvertes mais
aussi la création d'un jardin adapté on
est environ 13 1500 euros pour le
financement complet du jardin zen donc
la première action qu'on a mis en place
c'est la plateforme kiss kiss bang bang
de récolte de fonds qui se termine dans
dix jours
aujourd'hui cette cagnotte elle est à
presque 4000 euros on est à 3500 3600 et
quelques euros est l'objectif
au travers de cette plateforme est
énormément de récolter 500 euros pour
l'organisation des journées portes
ouvertes et tout le surplus serait
reversée à l'oeil mais en fait pour
contribuer à ce financement
une opération qui commence bien et aussi
le début d'une belle histoire puisque
les jeunes ne comptent pas s'arrêter là
au-delà de cette plateforme on souhaite
nous mettre en place par exemple le
montage de dossiers de demande de
financement
on veut aussi peut-être aller vers les
entreprises qui proposent ces devis et
négocier les prix une récolte qui
permettrait aux enfants du centre de
bénéficier d'une cour de récréation
adaptées à leurs besoins et qui semble
susciter l'engouement général
puisqu'elle a déjà rassemblé plus d'une
centaine de donateurs